Hallo und herzlich
kommen zu Raumzeit, dem Podcast über Raumfahrt und andere kosmische Angelegenheiten. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße alle zur 94. Ausgabe hier in dieser,
und schon im letzten Gespräch habe ich ja erzählt, ich bin äh nach Madrid gefahren und da sitze ich jetzt immer noch und nutze die Gelegenheit auch gleich noch für ein zweites, interessantes Gespräch, was in gewisser Hinsicht auch an das letzte anknüpft, nicht, äh weil wir über das James Web Teleskop weitere äh Fakten
bringen möchten, dem ist, glaube ich, ausreichend Rechnung getragen. Nein, jetzt soll's auch ein wenig um
die ISAG selber gehen und ähm
was sie hier überhaupt so äh gemacht und getan wird und noch sehr viel konkreter, wie man all diese ganzen Missionen plant und baut,
besondere im Hinblick auf Teleskope, die im All durch die Gegend schweben, aber auch die Teleskope, die auf der Erde bleiben.
Und dazu begrüße ich meinen Gesprächspartner heute nämlich Markus Kessler Pathig, hallo. Herzlich willkommen bei Raumzeit. Markus, ja, du bist hier ähm.
Head of Science.
Head of Science Operations.
Operations. Das klingt nach einer ganzen Mengen Arbeit.
Das ist ein Haufen Arbeit. Okay.
Und das machst du hier seit zwei Jahren oder so.
Fast drei mittlerweile genau und nicht nur hier also bei der Isar sondern die Gruppe spannt eben auch andere Standorte der Isar Baltimore und auch in Holland.
Mhm. Vielleicht mal erst mal zu dir, wie ähm bist du denn überhaupt zur Raumfahrt gekommen oder überhaupt zur Wissenschaft gekommen? Was war da die Motivation, wann fing das an?
Das äh von der ganzen Weile, also in den ähm äh Anfang der Ende der Achtziger habe ich angefangen, Physik zu studieren
und äh habe mich erst für Teilchenphysik interessiert, äh bin über Nutrinus dann zur Astronomie gekommen, habe äh promovierten Gastronomie.
Und dann eigentlich eine klassische Wissenschaftlerausbildung gemacht äh in den USA, äh viel Forschung. Ähm habe mich erst für eine akademische Laufbahn interessiert, aber bin davon schnell abgekommen.
Mitte 90er Jahre für Observatorien gearbeitet. Äh erst für die äh für die, für das European Tree, also für bodengebundene Teleskope
hab da angefangen Instrumentierung zu bauen und über die Instrumentierung kam ich dann so langsam rein in in Betrieb und von Großdeskopen.
Hab dann lange Instrumentierung gebaut für Teleskope, hab dann umgesattelt auf Großprojekte, was der wissenschaftliche Leiter für das ILT für das European Extremiskope
Bei der EsO und ähm habe das dann mitentwickelt. Bin dann äh noch weiter gegangen, habe dann äh zweitausendzwölf.
In die USA zurückgekehrt ähm und nach Hawaii gezogen für fünf Jahre, wo ich Direktor war von.
Dem International Germany Observaty, das sind großzügige Hawaii und in Chile, die ich da betrieben habe.
Und äh kam dann zurück zur Jesus später 2017 als stellvertretender Direktor für Wissenschaft
wurde von da von abgeworben für die also für jetzt Weltraum Teleskope und bin seit 2019 eben in Madrid und hier für die Wissenschaft und im Betrieb von den Weltraum Teleskopen zuständig.
Okay, gut rumgekommen, würde ich sagen.
Ja, ein paar Stationen und und viel dabei gelernt und ja, interessante Bögen geschlagen.
Mhm. War denn das so von vorneherein klar, so eine wissenschaftliche Karriere? War das schon immer.
Ich hab mich immer für für Forschung interessiert, ich glaube auch wenn man viele Forscher fragt die sind auch immer kreativ also ich hab im Studium mein Geld verdient indem ich Illustrator war also hab für 'ne Werbeagentur gearbeitet und illustriert.
Und ich kenne viele, die Musiker sind oder sonst was, also sie eine kreative Seite haben und wenn sie dann eben noch sich für Wissenschaft interessieren, laden sie auf den in Grundlagenforschung, was äh sehr
was so ganz anders ist als die Ingenieure, mit denen ich sehr viel zu tun hatte, das ist, ich sag mal, das sind die die Konservativen, Wissenschaftler und die äh,
die Forscher sind, die die freigeistigen Wissenschaftler äh und ich war eben eher einer der freigeistigen Wissenschaftler, ich könnte mich
so rigoros arbeiten wie ein Ingenieur und und ich glaube auch umgekehrt äh klappt das oft nicht gut. Aber so war es einfach ganz nett. Ähm ich habe mich für Wissenschaft interessiert, hatte das
äh in der Gastronomie gibt's eben wenig Stellen. Ähm es ist eine eine schwere Karriere, wenn man da die ersten zehn Jahre äh auf befristeten Stellen sitzt und äh und insbesondere, wenn man Familie hat,
vier Kinder auch äh immer sich wieder die Frage stellt, äh wie lange kann ich's noch auf diesem Job ernähren, wann muss ich umsatteln? Aber mir hat's eigentlich ganz gut geklappt. Ich habe mich äh ich habe
immer das Glück gehabt, spannende Sachen zu machen. Habe auch immer ähm mich für Lehre interessiert. Ich hatte auch ursprünglich mal auch ein bisschen auf Lehramt studiert und äh habe immer
gelehrt, seit 205 auch an der LEMU in München, wo ich dann später habe die Tiert habe und immer dort auch noch äh jetzt Privatdozent bin. Ähm.
Astrobiologie.
Also im Moment unterrichte ich Astrobiologie ursprünglich Astrophysik aber Astrologie Biologie hatte sich ergeben weil ich eben durch das Forschung der Exo-Planeten dann auch lernen wollte und.
So ergibt eins das andere.
Genau. Also es äh fing da alles zusammen. Ich habe auch immer wieder Gelegenheiten genutzt, äh andere Sachen zu tun, so bin ich eben viel rumgekommen und habe mich nie irgendwie äh gefürchtet, irgendwie mal was was Neueres zu lernen oder anzufangen und ähm.
Zum anderen.
Mhm,
Wenn ich das äh richtig mitbekommen habe, ähm war eigentlich so der Auslöser, ich meine, dass es sich dann so auf Teleskope äh eingeschwungen hat, hatte glaube ich damit zu tun, dass schon im Studium eine Beschäftigung mit Hubbel angesagt war, oder?
Im Studium hatte ich schon was mit gemacht, aber da war das, glaube ich, vielleicht noch ein wirklich äh da habe ich mich nie so richtig technisch in im technischen Bereichen gesehen. Und das kam eigentlich mit dem.
Mit
meinem zweiten Postdog, also dem beim ersten in Kalifornien, habe für die äh University of California Trees gearbeitet. Äh da war's im Zusammenhang mit Hubbel, da war es in Zusammen mit den ersten Großteleskopen in den USA, mit dem
und dass die Europäer dann Großteileskope gebaut haben, das wäre äh haben sie nach jungen Europäern gesucht, die eben Erfahrungen damit hatten.
Da wurde ich eben von der, vom als erst mal eingestellt.
Da habe ich angefangen, so ein bisschen mich für technische Sachen zu interessieren, Instrumentierungen, auch gesehen, dass man äh eine Schnittstelle braucht zwischen den
rein Akademikern, die wirklich diese Instrumentierung benutzen und den Ingenieuren, die sie bauen und man brauchte da eben eine Schnittstelle, die eben beide Welten versteht oder sich für beide interessiert.
Da bin ich dann drin gelandet und hab das angefangen für Instrumentierung für das 34 Instrumente betreut
und äh eben versucht immer zu erklären, den Ingenieuren, was jetzt überhaupt die Wissenschaft klar machen wollen mit dieser mit diesem Instrument, mit diesem Teleskop.
Und wie man das am besten technisch umsetzt und äh das hat mir Spaß gemacht.
Und ähm ich hab's natürlich dann auch ganz gut gemacht, weil man mich dann eben auf dieses große Teleskop angesetzt hat, auf das äh wo ich dann damals äh dann eben auch dieselbe Rolle hatte eben.
Die Definition überhaupt von dem von dem und dann wie man diese auf englisch oder die wissenschaftlichen.
Ziele eben den Ingenieuren erklärt und daraus eben äh äh.
Und technische äh Anforderungen eben äh entwickelt.
Ist eigentlich eine super spannende Schnittstelle, ne? Diese diese beiden Welten äh mehr oder weniger gleichzeitig abzudecken ohne oder mit beiden Sachen äh unmittelbar was zu tun zu haben.
Ja, also ich fand's auch immer äh ich habe sehr, sehr viel gelernt von beiden Seiten, also aus der Wissenschaft kam ich ja, das konnte ich eben sehr gut nachvollziehen
was ich lernen musste ist wirklich mit Ingenieuren zu arbeiten und was die Anforderungen sind wenn man überhaupt also das ILT ist 'n Milliardenprojekt, das ist 'n unglaublich komplexes System mit vielen Untersystemen
und ähm wie man da überhaupt äh wissenschaftliche Anforderungen übersetzt in in technische Anforderungen.
Wo die Grenzen sind, wo man verhandeln kann, wie Ingenieure ticken, wie man in hilft, weil letztendlich möchte man ihnen ja helfen, das Beste zu bauen.
Und äh das äh hat mich schon immer fasziniert und ähm dann ist mir natürlich auch sehr schnell in in Projektleitung und so bin ich eben auch in diesem Managementrollen reingerutscht.
Aber das mich hat's eben fasziniert wirklich das umzusetzen dieses wir haben wissenschaftliche Ideen ich forsche auch noch gerne ich hab auch noch Studenten aber wie ermöglicht es.
Ist es anderen Leuten äh wirklich zu forschen und mit mit Spitzen äh Apparatur, mit Spitzenteleskopen
ähm und das äh fand ich toll, hat Spaß gemacht, wenn was Spaß macht, dann ist man auch meistens erfolgreich drin und und das hat gut geklappt.
Mhm. Dann kommen wir doch vielleicht mal kurz auf die Rolle, die jetzt das
als Standort auch konkret spielt, weil ähm es scheint mir bisher am richtigen Ort, weil er im Prinzip genau diese Schnittstelle äh an dieser Stelle ja auch äh voll zum Tragen kommt. Also das Esack ähm kümmert sich ja auf der einen Seite.
Um die Wissenschaftler, also hat genau diese Anbindung an die ganzen äh Wissenschaftler weltweit verteilt, die eben.
Nach Daten hungern. Die Anforderungen haben ähm auf der einen Seite, aber es ist ja auch, aktiv beim.
Planung, bei der Entwicklung der äh Instrumente und der gesamten Systeme, sowohl bei den Space Missions als auch bei den Bodentelesgruppen mit dabei, richtig?
Ja, genau. Also ähm vielleicht um um kurz auszuholen, was die EZAG ist, also ist für European Stronname Center. Es ist eins von äh acht Standorten von der ESAF, also von der European Space Agency in in Europa
und äh ist aufgeteilt in in viele Programme. Ähm aber der der das Kernprogramm oder das äh also das Programm mit dem Esa gegründet worden ist, ist das Wissenschaftsprogramm
Und das ist eben hier am Esak angesiedelt. Ähm und wir kümmern uns also praktisch alles äh alle Wissenschaftsmissionen, die nach oben gucken.
Ich sage immer, dann gibt's noch welche, die nach unten gucken, das sind die Erdbeobachtungen, die sitzen bei uns in Italien. Äh wir haben ein riesen technisches Zentrum in Holland, wir haben Astronauten in in Deutschland.
Wir haben äh, was ich mir das äh und unser Houston nenne, das ist in Darmstadt, in dem Fall, wo man die Sathlettenkontrolle macht.
Aber die Wissenschaftsmission, die werden eben äh hier im äh Direktorat für Wissenschaften definiert und äh und gebaut und betrieben.
Und Esak ist eben ähm hier die der Standort für für Wissenschaftsmission.
Und ähm wir das Direktorat ist in in drei Teile äh gegliedert. Ähm.
Ein Teil macht technische Entwicklungsarbeit und guckt, was für Technologien nötig sind für die späteren Missionen.
Der zweite Teil baut wirklich die, arbeitet mit der Industrie zusammen und baut wirklich die Mission. Und der dritte Teil, das ist der Teil, den ich leite.
Spannt den Bogen. Also wir haben die Wissenschaftler da, die Wissenschaftler, die eben diese Ideen haben, was für Mission kommt zu also als nächstes dran, was sind die Anforderungen und die dann eben praktisch,
diese Arbeit machen, diese Schnittstelle sind äh zwischen der wissenschaftlichen Community und unseren Ingenieuren und eben da denen erklären, äh was jetzt als nächstes kommt.
Und ähm ja, wir sind dann eben betreuen maßgeblich eben diese Entwicklung, also die ähm erstmal die die Selektion und dann die Entwicklung dieser äh Mission.
Das Lustiges dran, dass wir dann alle Fehler dann selber ausbaden müssen, weil wir auch in diesem in meinem Department eben auch den Betrieb, den wissenschaftlichen Betrieb der Mission äh haben
so dass wir nachher die Mission betreiben müssen, die wir selber definiert haben und die Android für uns gebaut haben.
Also mit anderen Worten, man wird es auch nie los.
Man wird's nie los. Also und äh und das andere, was wir hier bei der haben, ähm ist ein äh ist das Archiv, das weltweit offen ist. Äh wir haben hier Daten von allen Missionen, die wir jeweils geflogen sind. Wir haben äh viele.
Spiegeln viele Daten von NASA-Missionen zum Beispiel, der auch äh die auch hier untergebracht sind. Ähm wir haben Daten von äh unseren Astronauten noch hier liegen und so, also wir haben auch ein riesiges Archiv, äh das wir hier betreiben.
Es gibt ein zweites Archiv in Italien auch für die Eheseite, für die Erdbeobachtung, aber das große äh Wissenschaftsgastronomiebetrieb äh Archiv, das äh das ist hier auch auf diesem Standort.
Das heißt, hier ist auch konkret ein Data-Center, wo das vorgehalten wird.
Ja genau, hier ist ein großes Starter-Center. Äh am anderen Ende vom Campus, wo wir gerade sitzen ähm und da wird auch alles gespeichert äh betrieben.
Viel viel Arbeit dahinter auch, dass man optimal die Daten der der Mission ausnutzen kann, dass man wenn man
Daten von einer Mission sucht oder bearbeitet man direkt sieht wie die anderen Missionen vielleicht da was mit auch beobachtet haben oder ähnliche Objekte oder wie die verknüpft sind die Daten, so dass man wirklich
nicht nur eine Mission, Daten von einer Mission auswerten kann, sondern.
Eben äh das komplette, die komplette flotte der Esel benutzen kann für seine Wissenschaft, äh dass man das eben äh erleichtert, äh das zu tun.
Also auch der Geier Katalog.
Geierkatalog ist hier. Der wurde hier auch mit äh also ähm viele dieser Missionen muss man sagen, sind zusammen mit der wissenschaftlichen Community äh geplant und entwickelt.
In der Regel ist es so, dass äh wir eine eine Dienstleistung sind, also wir versuchen für die Wissenschaftler in Europa und und weltweit zu arbeiten und ähm was die ESA gut kann, ist Satelliten bauen.
Sozusagen, was wir auch oft als Plattform bezeichnen. Also es es fliegt äh es kreist um die Erde oder es fliegt irgendwo ins Sonnensystem
Und äh was äh wo wir versuchen mit den Wissenschaftlern in äh an den Instituten quer durch Europa zu arbeiten, ist um die Instrumentierung an Bord des Satellitens zu entwickeln.
Wenn man wir haben so drei große Bereiche der Wissenschaft, wir haben die Astronomie, die sind eben sehr vergleichbar mit Boden gebundenen Teleskopen,
da also von dem, was wir beobachten, wie wir die die betreiben. Dann haben wir planetarische Missionen, die sind etwas anders, weil da fliegen wir wirklich durch das Sonnensystem und versuchen den Planeten zu erreichen, den zu umkreisen oder zu landen. Und äh und dort Forschung zu machen.
Und der dritte Bereich, den wir haben, ist äh Physik, also Sonnenphysik.
Und da auch fliegen wir in der Regel in Richtung Sonne, je nach nah oder weit, je nachdem was wir was wir brauchen, was wir beobachten müssen ähm und äh all diese Bereiche eben äh sind hier abgedeckt.
Und je nachdem, was es für eine Mission ist, haben die verschiedene Anforderungen, ob das jetzt dann Teleskop an Bord ist, äh für die Astronomiemission dann oft in verschiedenen Wellenlängen Bereichen ist äh von von.
Kurzwilligen, also oder äh hart Energie äh Röntgenstrahlen bis dann über sichtbares Licht zu Infrarotstrahlung.
Das sparen wir so in der Gastronomie ab. An Bord eines äh also für Planetarische Mission haben wir an Bord dann oft
zehn 12 Instrumente, äh die ganz verschieden sind, welche, die eben sich den Planeten von von weiter angucken, welche, die einfach nur die Umgebung des Satellitens messen, wenn wir durchs Magnetfeld fliegen, um da die Magnetfelder zu messen der Planeten oder
Teilchenströme oder Strahlung.
Ähm und dann wiederum die ähm Helio Mission, also die die äh Heliophysemissionen, die sind ähm da transportieren wir auch oft ähm,
zehn Instrumente an Bord eines Satelliten, um sowohl die Umgebung zu messen als auch zur Sonne hinzugucken und da Messung auf der Sonnenoberfläche zu machen.
Ja, die Instrumente sind ja so ein bisschen das Salz in der Suppe. Ähm wird oft übersehen.
Auch äh erstmal äh lernen, dass man's nicht immer unbedingt so an den Missionszielen selber, also an den.
Geographischen Missionszielen äh allein festmachen kann, sondern dass sich die Mission eben stark darunter äh darin unterscheiden.
Wie sie irgendwo hingucken und ähm welche Daten letzten Endes aufgenommen werden und das ja
oft auch Missionen scheinbar ähm alte Missionen wiederholen, aber sich vor allem dann dadurch unterscheiden, dass äh entweder ganz andere Daten aufnehmen oder zumindest das, was
früher schon mal aufgenommen wurde, einfach sehr viel besser aufnehmen können, wie man das jetzt zum Beispiel bei dem Geier äh Katalog ja äh gesehen hat, der Sternkatalog, ich hatte das hier in
Raum zahlt 76 mit Stefan Jordan, schon mal ausführlich äh besprochen, was da alles bei rausgekommen ist. Und das ist ja auch, glaube ich, eine der erfolgreicheren Missionen der äh Isar in der letzten Zeit, wenn ich.
Geradezu ein eine ja ein Spitzen, eine Spitzenmission.
Hat äh in den letzten zwei Jahren alle Rekorde geschlagen. Also ähm das war was, was mich persönlich überrascht hat, weil ich dachte, dass äh das Hubbel Weltraum Teleskop äh.
Nie äh übertroffen werden könnte. In ähm aber wenn man jetzt eine eine Metrik nimmt, wie viele.
Wissenschaftliche Veröffentlichungen pro Jahr äh mit einem Teleskop passieren, hat sich irgendwann mal Hubbel auf etwa 1000 Veröffentlichungen pro Jahr hochgeschraubt.
Habe das natürlich 30 Jahre alt und über 30 Jahre alt jetzt und und wird nie eingeholt werden, dass es Gesamtvolumen an Veröffentlichungen angeht. Aber in den letzten Jahren ähm als der Geier ähm äh Katalog
Die zweite Edition rauskam und jetzt eben die die frühe äh dritte Edition. Da ähm ist Gaia auf fünfzehn, 16hundert Publikationen pro Jahr, also anderthalbmal so viel wie ähm wie Hubbel gekommen. Äh und
um das einzuordnen. Die meisten Missionen
sind irgendwo zwischen 100 und 300 Publikationen pro Jahr, da will wir das schaffen, sind wir eben sehr froh und finden, das war schon eine sehr erfolgreiche Mission. Viele äh Wissenschaftler, die eben ein Interesse daran haben, die sich dran beteiligen, die damit was Interessantes publizieren,
Habe mit tausend Publikationen pro Jahr dachten wir wären nie einholbar und und hat jetzt anderthalb Mal so viel wie Hubbel und und fünfmal so viel wie eine erfolgreiche Mission und und zehn Mal oder 15 Mal so viel wie
unsere Standardmission sozusagen. Und das war ähm das war ein unerwarteter, enormer Erfolg.
Gut, ich meine, es ist ja auch eine totale Universal-Mission. Ich meine, äh wer vielleicht die alte Folge noch nicht gehört hat oder noch nicht so genau weiß, wovon wir sprechen, Geier ist ja eine Mission, die einfach ja.
Den Stern quasi den neuen Sternkatalog äh neu erfasst hat, also sprich unser gesamtes astronomisches Wissen darüber, wo befinden sich welche Objekte, woraus sind sie zusammengesetzt, wie schnell fliegen sie von A nach B,
zu was gehören sie überhaupt? Auch diese Langzeitbeobachtung über mehrere Jahre, die ja quasi so 'n.
Noch sehr viel dreidimensionaleres Modell äh erstellt hat, mit sehr viel mehr Rahmendaten als bisher Vorlagen und auch alles sehr viel noch äh sehr viel genauer noch erfasst hat, als es bisher möglich war. Das ist natürlich auch ein gefundenes Fressen und ich denke, dass aber auch die die Strategie
wie diese Daten veröffentlicht wurden, doch eine ganze Menge dazu beigetragen hat. Also es ist ja alles sofort allen bereitgestellt worden.
Ja genau, also es ist.
Der erwartete Effekt oder ähm.
Hoffnung, aber ich glaube nicht, dass sich die das jemand es äh je geträumt hätte, dass dass es so erfolgreich wird, äh weil die klassischen Gastronomie-Missionen, äh die werden betrieben wie Bodengebunden,
da wurde es mehr oder weniger definiert von einem, von einem Jahrhundert, als es diese großen Teleskope gab, aufm aufm Boden, ähm dass die Wissenschaftler eben.
Umbenutzen und jeder Wissenschaftler schlägt vor, was er da tun möchte, wenn es viel Druck auf dem Teleskop gibt, dann äh gibt es ein Prozess, also wo die Community eben entscheidet, was äh erfolgreiche Beobachtungen werden und
die bekommen dann Zeit. In der Regel beobachten die Wissenschaftler dann für sich selber.
Wir haben mittlerweile Archive, die Daten werden dann auch meistens nach einem Jahr öffentlich gemacht, aber sie werden hauptsächlich von einem Benutzer äh benutzt. Ähm und ähm.
Benutzer, der sozusagen auch definiert hat, wo wo schaut man überhaupt hin so? Aber das war ja bei Geier eh klar, wo man hinschaut, nämlich man schaut ja überall hin.
Genau und Geier, wo ist eine sogenannte eine Durchmusterungsmission. Das heißt, Geier äh ist ein Teleskop, das äh ähm sich auf um die eigene Achse dreht und eben äh also,
äh Himmelsbahnen abtastet und da eben die Sterne vermisst. Äh.
Und wieder und wieder und wieder, also um und zwar haben wir dann die die hellsten Sterne, das sind die Sterne unserer Milchstraßen und da hat zwei Milliarden von erfasst von in der Milchstraße gibt's.
Vielleicht 200 Milliarden. Man weiß man's mittlerweile genauer.
Ich glaube weniger ist das also es sind äh zehn auch zehn Sonnenmassen mehr oder weniger, unsere Galaxie und und die meisten Sterne sind halt äh weniger massiver als unsere Sonder. Also,
Äh
Wünscht mir die Zahl genau, aber ich würde abschätzen zwischen 10 und 50 Milliarden Sterne, aber zwei Milliarden Sterne ist schon ein ein Großteil der Sterne unserer Milchstraße und die sind eben auch ähm
homogen verteilt über den Himmel, das heißt man kann sehr sehr gut an wenn man diese Sterne vermisst,
und das hat eben unglaublich präzise gemacht, nicht nur die Position, sondern auch eben wie sich diese Sterne in mit der Zeit verschieben, wie sich bewegen, in welche Richtung sie fliegen
diese Daten als großer Katalog veröffentlicht worden sind,
unglaublich viele Projekte ansetzen, um die Milchstraße zu verstehen, um die Mischhas zu verstehen. Man kann eben durch diese äh genauen äh ähm Positionen noch Paralaxen bestimmt, das heißt Entfernungen zu sternen, die man eben
mit dem bloßen Auge kann man ja nicht erfassen, wie weit oder ein Stern ist, aber daher ermöglicht eben diese.
Entfernungen der Sterne zu bestimmen, wenn man eine Entfernung hat, eine genaue, kann man anfangen,
eine äh sichtbare Helligkeit äh in eine absolute Helligkeit umzurechnen. Das heißt, man kann anfangen wirklich.
Die physikalischen Eigenschaften dieser Sterne sehr, sehr genau zu bestimmen. Und dann hat das öfter seine Fenster auf diese ganze stillere Astrophysik äh dann die Leute an, besser die Größen der Sterne, die Temperaturen der Sterne, die Schwerkälte, sie ähm äh Oberflächen ähm.
Schwerkraft der Stelle zu verstehen, kann man sehr, sehr viel Sternphysik machen. Andererseits kann man eben diese Struktur der Milchstraße sehr gut verstehen oder viel, viel besser verstehen als früher, wie sich die Milchstraße
was für Komponenten sie hat, Scheiben, inneren Kern, ein wie sich zueinander verschalten
dann die komplexe Struktur der Milchstraße, alles was auf die Milchstraße,
draufgefallen ist, wir haben eben äh sehr viele Nachbargalaxien und viele von denen haben eben mit der äh Wann mit der Milchstraße in einer Wechselwirkung und wir können wir fangen an, eben diese ganzen Wechselwirkungen viel besser zu verstehen und nachvollziehen zu können
Dann gab's sehr seltene Objekte, von denen man eben vielleicht,
Weiße Zwerge zum Beispiel sind, sind eher selten. Äh und wenn man dann zwei Milliarden Sterne erfasst, hat man plötzlich einen riesigen Katalog, statt eben eine eine Handvoll von äh diesen speziellen Objekten zu haben, hat einen Punch hunderte von diesen speziellen Objekten und kann eben diese spezielle Kategorie
Zwerge als Beispiel viel besser studieren und verstehen als früher. Und so kam es eben, dass Gaya,
dadurch dass es eben 'ne Durchmusterung war, dass man eben nicht das diese Daten unterteilt hat, sondern die wirklich aus ganzen Katalog veröffentlicht hat und auch sofort.
Wissenschaftlern weltweit zugänglich gemacht hat, hat man da eben unglaublich viel Forschung in ganz verschiedenen Gebieten ermöglicht. Und das hat die Mission, glaube ich, so erfolgreich gemacht.
Und wird das dazu führen, dass es in Zukunft häufiger getan werden wird oder vielleicht so der neue Standard wird?
Es wird äh glaube ich
schon zum neuen Standard, also die die NASA hat schon beschlossen, dass die ähnlichen Missionen, die es in Zukunft die Nase betreiben wird, eben auch die selbe äh Daten äh,
haben soll. Äh und die Daten sofort veröffentlicht werden, veröffentlicht werden sollen und auch vorbereitet werden sollen, so dass die Wissenschaftler sie benutzt
sofort benutzen können und nicht selber erstmal ähm diese.
Rohdaten filtern da filtern und so. Mhm.
Ähm und wir haben auch einige Missionen, die noch äh kommen und äh wo wir eben ähnlich vorgehen wollen. Wir haben eine ist eine, die äh nächstes oder spätestens übernächstes Jahr äh starten wird, die äh auch eine Art Durchmusterung machen wird
aber nicht um,
nah, also nahe und so Milchstraße zu studieren, sondern guckt eben in weite Ferne und versucht eben die, die Struktur des kompletten Universums zu verstehen. Etwa auf der selben Grundlage, große Durchmusterung und dann diese Daten an viele, viele Wissenschaftler schon verarbeitet geben.
Damit die eben Beschleunigungsuniversums, dunkle Materie, dunkle Energie und diese Phänomene eben damit studieren kann.
Die anderen Mission, die ähnliches äh uns so einig sein wird, ist die Mission. Da wollen wir eine große Durchmusterung machen und äh möglichst alle Exoplaneten oder Planetensysteme um uns rum erfassen und äh und äh auch
Kataloge erstellen, die vorbereiten für die Wissenschaftler und dann allen Wissenschaftlern sehr schnell Zugang zu geben.
Ist das, wo wir uns eben maximalen Durchbruch wissenschaftlicher.
Bleiben wir doch nochmal ganz kurz bei Geya, aber aus einer anderen Perspektive heraus, nämlich dieser Perspektive der Arbeit, die wir jetzt äh eingangs schon beschrieben haben, die haben Isaak gemacht wird. Womit fängt sowas an?
Also die meisten Missionen und
und das gleiche Prinzip gilt für für große Disco aufm aufm Boden. Fangen meistens mit äh
einer Idee an, die in der Community oft äh einfach geboren wird, äh wo sich dann Leute zusammentun und sagen, Mensch, das wäre doch das nächste, größte Denken. Also mit dem damit könnten wir einen wissenschaftlichen Durch,
äh erzielen. Ähm.
Dann äh sind diese Missionen oft sehr teuer, äh ein paar hundert Millionen Euro bis zu einer Milliarde oder mehr äh oder ganz extrem, wie jetzt das äh Hubbel oder das neue Huble, James Webstays guckt, ist man bei zehn oder plus Milliarden.
Wie lange dauert denn das, bis man überhaupt auf so einen Preis kommt? Ich meine, wenn ich mir jetzt vorstelle, dass so eine Gruppe der also erstmal muss ja sozusagen diese Idee.
Klar, muss man erstmal haben, aber dann äh.
Es besteht ja der Wunsch, alles Mögliche zu erforschen und ich denke mal, da sind sich die Wissenschaftler ja nicht von heute auf morgen einig, sondern irgendeiner Form muss ja erstmal so ein Konsens gebildet werden, so ja, das ist jetzt auch so ein Ziel, da stehen sehr viele dahinter und mehr als hinter anderen Zielen.
Genau und damit fängt eigentlich alles immer an, also dass wir praktisch in äh in regelmäßigen Abständen, das sind.
Abstände von 1 bis manchmal 20 Jahre. Wir haben gerade jetzt einen solchen Prozess hinter uns. Die äh Community befragen und ähm.
Praktisch alle einladen, äh zu einem Konsens zu kommen, was die großen wissenschaftlichen Themen sind, also überhaupt erstmal Themen, nicht unbedingt wie man sie in eine Mission umsetzt, sondern Themen.
Wo findet das statt auf Konferenzen oder gibt's da elektronische Kommunikationen? Was.
Es findet auf Konferenzen statt, oft auf auf wirklich.
Zielgerichtete Konferenzen, also die, das, was die Esel jetzt gerade gemacht hat, das äh haben wir voyage twenty-fifty genannt, also ähm um praktisch die Mission zu definieren, die in den 2040ern, 2050er Jahren.
Fliegen werden. Das heißt, wir planen praktisch eine Generation in die Zukunft. Und so haben es auch einige Generationen vor uns, die Leute gemacht, für die Mission, die wir heute fliegen,
Ähm wir rufen dann alle auf, äh sich äh äh oder freiwillig zu melden, um äh mit zu machen. Und bilden dann ein ziemlich großes Komitee äh mit.
Viel Expertise mit, also der Expertise der gesamten Community, äh die dann, weil wiederum Konferenzen organisieren, wo dann alle
wirklich erscheinen können und jeder kann auch einfach einen einen was wir nennen, also einen Vorschlag
niederschreiben und das auch einschicken. Und dieses, äh, diese Gruppe, die, der Freiwilligen, ähm, zwanzig Leute, dreißig Leute
setzt sich dann hin und arbeitet wirklich ein, zwei Jahre durch, um rauszufiltern, um um große Themen auszuarbeiten und so weiter und stellt sie dann vor
und das ist dann eine Art Konsensbildung, wo wir dann wissen, gut diese Themen sind die uns wichtigen Themen für die nächsten zwei, drei Jahrzehnte.
Ähm und die arbeiten wir dann so langsam ab.
Äh zum Beispiel ähm ein Thema, das es jetzt rauskristallisiert hat, ist, dass wir gerne die Mode von riesen Planeten, ähm also vom Jupiter, vom Saturn erforschen würden.
Weil wir uns da eben erhoffen, dass beim einigen von denen, die die zu einer Eiskruste haben, eben aber oft einen flüssigen Ozean unter der Oberfläche äh eventuell äh Zeichen von Leben oder äh Bausteine für Leben eben finden könnten.
Das ist immer ein großes Thema. Ähm da wird's dann dazu in den nächsten ein, zwei Jahren eine Ausschreibung geben und äh sagen, gut, wir würden eine solche Mission fliegen.
Ähm entwickelt man Konzepte. Was dann passiert in der Community ist, dass dann sich die Leute wirklich hinsetzen und äh sich überlegen.
Wie würde so eine Mission aussehen? Zu welchem Mond möchte ich fliegen? Ist es ein Mond von mir bitte? Ist ein Mond vom Saturn? Welcher? Welche sind interessant? Das ist der Titan, es ist Enzelarus, es ist verschiedene Eigenschaften,
ähm in der Regel gibt's dann verschiedene Vorschläge. Dann laden wir wieder die Community ein, äh das eben sich anzuschauen, also.
Wir arbeiten sehr viel mit diesen Peer-Reviews, also mit ähm.
Gegenseitigen Abprüfen von PayPal dann, mhm.
Genau und äh und eine Selbstevalubation der Community, die dann sagst, gut, nach reifem Überlegen denken wir, dass.
Dass die Mission wird die ähm erfolgreichsten äh sein kann. Ähm und die,
nehmen wir dann, also diese Studien führen wir dann oft parallel, wir helfen der Community auch zu definieren OK ihr braucht etwa die Technologie, die ist reif oder nicht, die müsste, die brauch ich dann nochmal fünf Jahre Entwicklung
Und das ist oft ein Prozess, der fünf bis zehn Jahre dauert, bis wirklich diese Mission definiert ist und bis man dann auch wirklich weiß, wie viel wird sie kosten. Wir haben
Also wir gehen davon aus, dass äh je nachdem, was für eine Ausschreibung das war,
dass wir ein gewisses Volumen an Geld bereitstellen, aber es kann sein, dass sich diese Kosten halbieren oder verdoppeln, je nachdem wie ähm wie ambitioniert die Mission wird.
Vielleicht, dass die Technologie noch nicht reif wird, dann verschieben wir die Mission wieder ein bisschen oder wir stellen fest, dass wir mit Sicherheit vereinfacht, wie wir sie direkt fliegen können. Äh und das für diese wirklich großen Mission ist das ein Prozess, der fast ein Jahrzehnt.
Dauert und dann dauert's etwa noch fast ein Jahrzehnt bis die dann gebaut wird bis wir dann wirklich also die mit der Industrie zusammenarbeiten um den Satelliten zu entwickeln, mit der mit den verschiedenen Instituten quer durch Europa arbeiten,
um die ganze Instrumentierung fertigzustellen, die dann an Bord kommt, die ganzen äh Testverfahren, also insbesondere für Weltraummissionen ähm ist es nochmal wirklich äh ein Schritt komplizierter als für Boden, gebundene Teleskope, wo man immer wieder hin kann und nochmal über dieses Tier oder korrigieren oder nachbessern.
Muss alles stimmen, ne?
Da muss alles sofort stimmen, das heißt ähm es ist praktisch wirklich äh fast also fünf bis zehn Jahre Studie und 5 bis zehn Jahre Bau.
Und dann nach zehn bis 20 Jahren äh wird die dann wirklich gestartet und äh und der füllt dann hoffentlich ihre Mission und ähm.
Wenn man an Bord vier Streit Treibstoff braucht oder ähm alles, was eben sich verbraucht, dann kann es sein, dass sie die Mischung,
nur kurzlebig ist, vielleicht nur fünf Jahre.
Wenn's geht betreiben wir die natürlich so lange wie's wie möglich also der Europäer fliegt schon seit über zwanzig Jahren,
Hatte ich vorhin erwähnt, schon über 30 Jahre. Äh irgendwann war natürlich, dass es wie ein Kleinwagen, den man nie zur Werkstatt bringen kann, äh dann die haben alle irgendwie einen.
Genau, also im im Weltall nicht durchrosten, aber aber manche Teile werden einfach so oft benutzt, äh weil's einfach bewegliche Teile sind, dass die dann irgendwann mal äh kritische Teile auseinanderfallen und das dann meistens das Ende. Aber wir versuchen sie,
solange ähm diese diese Mission aktiv wissenschaftlich genutzt werden, versuchen wir sie zu fliegen und weiter zu betreiben bis ans bittere technische Ende.
Wie ist denn das gerade bei Gaya? Geyer hat ja im Prinzip seinen Auftrag jetzt erstmal soweit erfüllt oder eigentlich sogar auch über.
Geier hat sein, hatte eine äh Art fünf Jahre gebraucht, um seinen Auftrag zu erfüllen,
und konnte äh und es war schon vorgesehen, dass wenn man es um etwa fünf Jahre verlängert
es eben nochmal uns eine äh einen Schritt weiterbringen würde. Und weil alles so gut verlaufen ist
ähm also mit den üblichen Problemen, zum Beispiel, wir haben an, an Bord eines Satellitens immer eine Rennundanz für Systeme, die kritisch sind, äh so Transponder zum Beispiel, also wo wir kommunizieren, die Daten zurückschicken zur Erde,
haben wir immer zwei an Bord. Geil hat irgendwann mal einen verloren. Das heißt, hätte es den zweiten auch verloren, könnte Geil jetzt zwar wunderschön messen, aber die Daten überhaupt nicht mehr an uns äh,
weiterleiten.
Also Geier fliegt schon seit einer Weile mit nur einem Transponder, also äh das heißt, wir sind immer, wir schwitzen immer ein bisschen, wenn wenn der andere so ein bisschen äh wackelt. Ähm,
das Teleskop dreht sich um seine eigene Achse und man muss es eben kontrollieren können, auch die Ausrichtung,
und dazu braucht man eben minimal Treibstoffe, man braucht eben Treibstoff und der ist dann irgendwann mal alle
und Geier äh hat eben seine fünfersten Jahre erfüllt, ist jetzt gerade am, also am in der ersten
Periode seiner nächsten fünf Jahre und wenn alles gut technisch läuft, wird der Treibstoff uns eben tatsächlich nach zehn Jahren etwa ausgehen und in dem Fall eben mein zwanzig, fünfundzwanzig wird gar ja dann kein Treibstoff mehr haben und äh
mit dem letzten Treibstoff ins Weltall Richtung, also Sonne geschickt, wird dann in die Sonne fallen, damit's irgendwie kein äh
verletzt oder kein Weltraumschrott wird. Äh und dann verabschieden wir uns mit einem äh schönen Feuerwerk äh und freuen uns über die ganzen Daten.
Was ist denn die Erwartung, wie sich die Daten nochmal verbessern.
Einfach indem man längere Zeit reinmisst, also dass man praktisch, wenn man die Sternbewegung haben will, kann man sie natürlich kleine Bewegungen,
Minimale Bewegung könnte man in fünf Jahren fast keinen also
gar nicht bemerken, wenn wir mit einem Zehnjahres äh Zeitraum könnte man tatsächlich auch Sterne vermessen, die sich sehr langsam bewegen und da eine Eigenbewegung vermessen. Ähm andererseits natürlich je öfter man die Sterne misst und man misst's immer äh relativ zu anderen Sternen.
Je mehr Vergleichpunkte man hat, desto genauer kann man eben eine ähm äh.
Bestimmung machen et cetera.
Andererseits versuchen wir auch was wir Fotometrie nennen, also einfach die Helligkeiten vermessen in verschiedenen Filtern und da sind auch eben mehrere Messungen immer präziser als eine einzelne Messung
wir machen auch sogenannte Spektroskopie von den hellsten Sternen, also.
Woraus das alles besteht.
Und da auch, wenn wir je mehr wir Licht sammeln und je öfter man einen Stern anguckt, desto mehr Licht sammelt man für einen Stern. Also es gibt viele Aspekte, die man eben dann äh dann verbessert. Äh irgendwann mal äh.
Verbessert sich äh sind die Verbesserungen nur noch minimal. Aber im Fall von Gaya ist eben der Schritt von 5 auf zehn Jahre verlängert, noch ein deutlicher äh
ein deutscher Fortschritt. Viel länger hätte man denn nur noch minimal Fortschritte machen können, deswegen war die auch von vorneherein designt. Etwa zehn Jahre äh zehn Jahre zu dauern.
Die Mission ist allerdings dann nicht zu Ende. Also was ich noch sagen wollte, ist dann der der Satellit ist zwar dann äh äh wird dann verglühen irgendwann mal
aber die Daten sind dann noch hier und diese die Verarbeitung der Daten, die wird wahrscheinlich nochmal fünf Jahre dauern, also bis man die kompletten Kataloge angefertigt hat, bis man diese Daten alle wirklich äh so vorbereitet hat, dass sie wissenschaftlich nutzbar sind, dass man eben.
Wir hoffen uns noch eben eine eine eine volle Version drei des Katalogs rauszubringen, aber auch noch eine Version vier und eine Version fünf.
Das wird dann nochmal nach dem Ende der Mission vielleicht fast fünf Jahre dauern. Ähm und dann hätte Geier endgültig seine Mission erfüllt, dann hätten wir die fünfte Version des Katalogs, die dann wahrscheinlich.
Also ein halbes Jahrhundert wird sie Bestand haben und und allen Wissenschaftlern dann äh dann wirklich noch dienen.
Unnormal ein halbes Jahrhundert auch äh Pappers erzeugen. Habe ich so den Eindruck, weil.
Noch ein halbes Jahrhundert beweis.
Das ist ja nun wirklich das Grundgerüst
Okay, aber machen wir jetzt nicht alles unbedingt an äh Gaia äh fest, weil es ist ja letztlich auch nur eine Mission. Dieser ganze Prozess ähm der Planung mh sind da jetzt ähm schnell durchgegangen.
Punkt, an dem man Kosten
machen muss. Ist ja jetzt auch nicht unbedingt etwas, was jetzt Wissenschaftlern so liegt. Also diese Einschätzung, was kostet überhaupt irgendetwas insbesondere im Hinblick darauf, dass man ja vielleicht sagt
Okay, wenn wir das jetzt planen, dann bauen wir das Ding ja auch erst frühestens in zehn oder 15 Jahren.
Wir hätten gerne eine Technologie, die es ja aber jetzt unter Umständen noch gar nicht gibt
wie kann man denn überhaupt Kosten einschätzen für eine Technik, die noch gar nicht erfunden ist?
Also die Wissenschaftler, also der Prozess fängt meistens so an und und das war auch meine erste Erfahrung, dass man als Wissenschaftler sich das natürlich alles wünscht. Und und denkt so, Mensch, Durchbruch wäre, wenn.
So genau vermissen kann, äh so viel erfassen kann und so weiter. Und mit diesen wissenschaftlichen Anforderungen geht man dann zum
Ersten zu den Ingenieuren und und lege die davor. Und die ganz übliche Reaktion der Ingenieure ist, sie schlagen sich die Hände von Kopf und und denken so, diese bescheidenen Wissenschaftler, die haben überhaupt keine Ahnung, was möglich ist und was nicht und.
Die die wollen jetzt irgendwas, was vielleicht in einem Jahrhundert möglich ist, aber aber jetzt noch überhaupt nicht. Oder eben äh Dutzende von Milliarden kosten würde und äh und unser Budget ist eben eine Milliarde. Ähm.
Riesige Summen sind, aber äh und und dann fängt so ein Interationsprozess an, wo die Wissenschaftler dann anfangen, zu versuchen, die die Ingenieur zu verstehen, wo die Ingenieure vielleicht mal was falsch verstanden haben und wo es eine einfache Möglichkeit gibt, äh da vielleicht.
Äh
kleineren Einschränkungen, es sehr sehr viel billiger zu machen äh und das ist ein Prozess, der dauert eine ganze Weile, auch was für Technologien man braucht, da ähm
die Ingenieure nehmen auf die die Wissenschafter wörtlich und und das ist eben das Interessante zu sehen, wie dann so langsam man sich annähert und nee, das meine ich überhaupt nicht so und und wenn du mir 90 Prozent davon gibst, dann ist ja auch toll und da können wir eine ganz andere Technologie verwenden, die sehr viel billiger ist und die es schon gibt
ähm äh manchmal ist das nicht der Fall. Also äh Gravitationswellen ist zum Beispiel ein gutes Beispiel. Da mussten wir eine komplette Mission finden, äh fliegen,
denn dieser Paarfinder, bevor wir überhaupt uns überzeugen konnten selber, dass äh Lisa dieses, also äh wo wir.
Eigentlich geplante.
Das Geplante, dass wir jetzt eben äh das äh unterwegs ist, also das äh kommt, aber dass eben äh noch ähm mindestens äh anderthalb Jahrzehnte, also zehn5 Jahre dauern wird, bis es äh bis es da ist. Äh aber da fliegen wir halt
die sind jeweils Millionen Kilometer voneinander entfernt und müssen.
Relative Entfernung zueinander auf einen Bruchteil von einem Atommessen, ja? Also das, wenn, wenn man das so sagt, dann dann.
Hört auf aber das ist was wo die Technologien entwickelt werden und wir uns dann irgendwann mal.
Man muss irgendwo anfangen und und äh da macht man halt den Anfang und guckt, okay Technologie für Technologie hangeln wir uns dann da hoch.
Die fliegenden Goldwürfel im äh Weltall, die diese Abstände dann letzten Endes äh.
Äh ja genau. Und aber gut, nicht alle Missionen sind so kompliziert. Wir haben äh auch Mission, wo wir wissen, okay, das ist relativ Standard. Äh da wollen wir halt äh vielleicht für die nächste Röntgenmission ähm.
Ist eine unserer größeren Missionen auch von der ESA äh auch etwa in einem Jahrzehnt äh geplant.
Nachfolger von eben XM, war ein extrem erfolgreiches Röntgenteleskop, das jetzt auch schon über 20 Jahre fliegt, vielleicht nochmal zehn Jahre betrieben werden kann, auch da, wenn es keine technischen Probleme gibt
Und da wollen wir einfach die Empfindlichkeit ähm äh verbessern. Das heißt, wir wollen einen größeren Spiegel, äh einen Spiegel mit dem Röntgenstrahlen
einfangen kann. Es ist gar nicht so leicht, es ist kein klassischer Spiegel, wo die Röntgenstrahlen eben wie wie optisches Licht einfach reflektiert werden, sondern man versucht eher diese Röntgenstrahlen zu kanalisieren auf den äh auf den Detektor ähm.
Das sind Technologien, die kennen wir, die wissen wir, wie's funktionieren soll, aber haben jetzt einen sehr viel höheren Anspruch, weil wir
normalerweise so etwa ein Faktor zehn besser sein wollen mit der nächsten Mission, dass mit der vorherigen, wenn es in der Mission des ähnlichen Typs
und für diese Technologien eben entwickelt werden müssen, wo wir auch abschätzen müssen, wie viel kostet das, wo wir auch manchmal wissen, gut hier ist jetzt in der Industrie gibt's ein, zwei äh Betriebe, die das entwickeln können
dann geht vielleicht nur einer Pleite, dann müssen wir gucken, können wir eine neue Industrie, um diese Technologie aufbauen.
Und dass eben dieser Iterationsprozess, wo wir dann oft über einige Jahre dann letztendlich diese Mission definieren.
Und wenn du einen Wissenschaftler und Ingenieure einig sind, dann,
man das Ganze ein, dass ja keiner auf die Idee kommt, ach lass uns doch noch eine Kaffeemaschine dazu einbauen, also und dann wird das alles doppelt so teuer.
Sondern er wird wirklich festgelegt, okay, hier hören wir auf
wir haben dann praktisch Abstriche gemacht an die Wissenschaft. Die Ingenieure sind überzeugt, dass sie's äh hinkriegen, auch wenn's vielleicht mit hohen Kosten oder Entwicklungsarbeit äh verbunden ist.
Und ähm das ist das, was wir in unserem äh Jargon dann äh mischen, Adoption nennen. Wo wir dann alles einfrieren,
inklusive dem Preis. Das äh wird den Mitgliedsländern vorgestellt und gesagt, hier, wir denken, wir könnten das für diese Mission äh für diesen Preis bauen. Äh kriegen dann äh grünes Licht und dann fängt diese Bauperiode, die Bauphase an von 5 bis zehn Jahren.
Diese diese Abstimmung, wenn du jetzt sagst, die Wissenschaftler auf der einen Seite, Ingenieure auf der anderen Seite, ist ja jetzt nicht nur so zwei
ganz unterschiedliche Arbeitsbereiche, sondern meist sind ja die Wissenschaftler sehr viel mehr in so einem universitären Umfeld unterwegs.
Während die Ingenieure jetzt in Anführungsstrichen äh tatsächlich ja mehr aus privaten Unternehmen.
Dann bestehen die also wirklich konkret, die Sathliten bauen, et cetera. Ist das, ist dieser, äh ist da auch nochmal so ein Kulturbruch, der da noch mit äh reinkommt oder ist das eher Segen.
Also das ist äh nee, das sind wirklich zwei verschiedene Welten, die da auch aufeinander treffen. Äh auch für Leute, die dann schon Erfahrung damit hatten. Das ist immer wieder äh wunderschön und interessant zu sehen. Äh und fürchte ich kompliziert und und äh es gibt
vieles Haare raufen äh ähm
viele Diskussionen, viele äh erhitzte Diskussionen, ähm weil wirklich die äh Wissenschaftler
vorhin nochmal schon mal erwähnt habe, Freigeistler sind, also die wollen äh die wollen versuchen, die wollen probieren, die die sind agil, die die wollen immer neues entdecken,
und äh so kann man keine Weltraummission bauen, weil man da ständig die Anforderungen ändern würde und und äh.
Wenn wir zu einem Schluss noch kurz was ändert, bei einem Satelliten, der den schickt man dann ins All und der funktioniert nicht, das das niemals.
Die Ingenieure, die kommen eben aus 'ner ganz viel rigoroseren Kultur, die die müssen eben dafür stehen, dass das, was hochgeschickt wird oder ins Weltall geschickt wird, dann funktioniert und zwar,
mit 99 Punkt neun neun neun Prozent im Wahrscheinlichkeit die arbeiten viel rigorosa, die sind konservativer also ein guter Ingenieur ist konservativ, der.
Probiert's jetzt dich mal kurz und schauen wir mal, was passiert, wenn wir hier mal kurz was ändern im Milliardenprojekt, äh wann ist das dem die Milliarde futsch, äh wenn das wirklich mal ein riesiger Fehler war.
Und die Wissenschaftler meistens auch dafür zuständig sind, die Instrumentierung zu bauen, ist bei uns oft die Instrumentierung das, was.
Was am schwersten zu kontrollieren ist, was Zeitskalen angeht, was Kosten angeht, weil die Wissenschaft immer noch ein bisschen was dran dann,
wollen oder auch universitäre Systeme sind unsicherer und man weiß nicht, wann man die den nächsten Studentengruppe oder die die.
Dann weiterarbeiten können und so. Ähm während die Ingenieure, die tatsächlich äh Rigos arbeiten, das sind die, die wirklich mit der Industrie arbeiten, die äh im industrielle Prozesse,
leiten und ähm die eine ganz andere Angehensweise an Projekte haben, die ähm äh.
Viel kontrollierter auch äh über die die Zeitskahlen ähm.
Mit festen Zeisskarren arbeiten, die ihre Kosten versuchen wirklich in unter Kontrolle zu halten und so weiter. Also sind auch wirklich diese,
äh Projektmanagementkulturen, die oft aufeinander treffen und wo wir dann immer so ein bisschen äh versuchen, als als äh Mittelmann äh ähm oder Mittel,
Vermittler eben da diese zwei Welten zusammenzubringen, dass dann letztendlich, wenn beide zusammenkommen, wenn Instrumente in in den Satelliten eingebaut werden müssen
dass das dann auch harmonisiert und äh auf Zeitsgang passiert, die wir äh vorher vorgesehen haben und auch in den Kosten, die wir vorgesehen haben.
Manche Instrumente werden ja aber auch im universitären Kontext entwickelt. Ist das eher die Ausnahme oder hält sich das so fifty fifty.
Also fast alle Instrumente werden dem universellen Kontakt ähm ausgearbeitet. Also die ähm nur wenn es wirklich größere Instrumente sind, die äh industrielle Prozesse brauchen.
Dann werden sie von der Industrie entwickelt, aber die in der Regel ist es wirklich so Plattform Satellits also.
Äh also der der stammt wird in der Industrie entwickelt. Die ganze Instrumentierung wird an den Unis oder Forschungslaboren äh entwickelt. Und das sind eben diese zwei Kulturen, die aufeinander treffen.
Jetzt ähm sind wir quasi an dem Punkt.
Mission, ganz gerne ein paar Beispiele äh nennen, wo sich das vielleicht gut festmachen kann, so sagen wir mal, eine Mission hat jetzt ihren äh diesen Punkt erreicht. Man ist sich über die Kosten einig, man hat
go. Man weiß, welche Instrumente man äh haben will, was die können soll, wie das Ding gebaut werden soll und es liegt mehr oder weniger auch so einen Zeitplan jetzt schon bereit, das heißt, das.
Ganze geht dann in diese Bauphase über. Ähm die äh ja, der der eigentliche Satit wird äh gebaut.
Wie wird denn das jetzt dann weiter begleitet? Wer wer tritt denn jetzt zu diesem Zeitpunkt noch mit mit ein?
Also man versucht zu dem Zeitpunkt dann die Wissenschaftler rauszuhalten, weil die würden kommen und wollen dann nochmal alles ändern. Also,
wirklich dann zu dem Zeitpunkt alles einzufrieren. Das heißt, ähm äh um zurückzukommen auf diese drei großen Abteilungen, die wir im äh Direktor für Wissenschaft haben, übernimmt dann äh unsere äh Projektsabteilung das
und die schließen dann Verträge, verbindliche Verträge mit der Industrie ab.
Für Satelliten, das sind große Verträge, sind Verträge von 100, 200 Millionen und die haben dann praktisch ähm äh,
Teams, die dann diese Verträge abschließen, vorbereiten, verfolgen, äh mit der Industriearbeiten sie ähm auf Zack halten und so weiter,
Teams müssen dann auf der anderen Seite eben auch mit äh den Unis arbeiten und die eben äh etwa im selben Schritttempo äh dazu anhalten, dass sie eben auch die Instrumentierung liefern.
Und ähm.
Letztendlich ist, sind die dafür zuständig, dass dann alles zusammenkommt und die sind auch zuständig, dass das alles verpackt wird und auch für den äh Launch, also äh.
Ob es den Erd- äh Erdumlaufbahnen oder ins äh ins Sonnensystem geschickt wird. Und in dem Moment, wo sie
wo das auf der richtigen Bahn ist und äh ähm alles demonstriert ist, dass es eben funktioniert an Bord. Übergeben sie das an die Abteilung, die dann den Betrieb aufnimmt. Also das ist äh meine Abteilung.
In dieser Zeit, also gleichzeitig werden zwei andere äh Kern ähm Komponenten entwickelt für eine Mission.
Einerseits, was wir Mission Operations nennen oder Mission Operation Center
Also das heißt, die äh die ganze Kommunikation mit dem Satelliten, ähm alles, was äh Software an Board ist äh und so weiter
von unseren Kollegen bei der ESOG, also in in Darmstadt entwickelt, das sind die Leute, die später wirklich, die sind Sattel kontrollieren müssen und ausrichten, dorthin, wo die Wissenschaftler ihn haben wollen.
Äh für den Teil des Betriebs,
Und der zweite große Teil ist eben dieses Science Operations, also das heißt ähm wir hier bei der ESAG entwickeln dann alles, was für den Wissenschaft und Betrieb nötig ist. Das heißt, ähm,
wenn es planetarische Missionen sind, müssen wir die Möglichkeit haben, Pläne zu entwickeln, wenn wir dann einmal im Umlauf ist von Maas zum Beispiel, was wird jeden Tag beobachtet, welche Instrumente werden ein- und ausgeschaltet, wie kommen die Daten runter und so weiter. Diese ganzen
also Planungstools, was ihr alles raufschicken zu beseitigen, damit der
weiß, was er zu tun hat jeden Tag und dann eben auch die Daten kommen dann wieder runter und wir müssen eben verstehen, wie wie wir die verarbeiten
die ganzen Prozesse und Systeme, die eben diese Daten von Rohdaten in wissenschaftliche Daten umwandeln, werden hier entwickelt
und eben dieses ganze ähm die Seite des Archivs wird äh wird hier dann in zwischenzeitlich entwickelt. Das heißt, während die Hardware,
von diesem Debatten für Projekts entwickelt wird entwickeln gleichzeitig,
die Leute bei der eine Mission Operation Center, die Leute bei der ISAC entwickeln ein Science Operation Center und diese drei großen Komponenten kommen dann am Schluss zusammen.
So dass man praktisch die Hardware hat, den Satelliten und die Instrumentierung an Bord und eben ein System, um diesen Satelliten auszurichten und zu kontrollieren
und gleichzeitig diese komplette Infrastruktur, die man braucht, um dann die wissenschaftliche Wissenschaft rauszuholen, sowohl dies alles, was man an Steuerungsbefehlen hochschickt, als auch diese Datenverwertung, wenn sie eben wieder runterkommt.
Mhm. Und dann, wenn man alles richtig gemacht hat, dann äh gibt's den Start.
Genau, nach fünf bis zehn Jahren hat man dann praktisch alles zusammen, testet es, äh es kann es können sehr lange Tests sein, jetzt wie für James Webs hat's eben äh Jahre gedauert, bis man wirklich sich sicher war, alles funktioniert rein, muss los. Äh und dann kommt eben äh der.
Beziehungsweise ja auch mehrfach festgestellt hat, so geht's nicht.
Genau und
einmal zurück und dann von vorne anfangen. Äh also so kam eben oft und irgendwie ist ein kleiner Fehler ist, da verzögert sich so drei Monate, wenn's ein größerer Fehler ist, verzögert sich schon drei Jahre
ähm also da hat man eben noch Überraschungen, aber wenn man sich dann sicher ist, das System dieser Sattel, diese Mission fliegt jetzt und wir haben alles vorbereitet, wie es sich gehört
dann kommt eben der große Tag des des Launchs, also dann äh werden natürlich vorher schon definiert mit äh welche Trägerrakete eben je nachdem nach Gewicht und Größe des Sattellitz eben äh den Sattel dorthin bringt, wo wir ihn haben wollen
äh in vielen Fällen ist es eben eine Erdumlaufbahn, für viele Gastronomie-Missionen möchte man einfach nur über der Atmosphäre sein, um entweder an die Wellenlängen ranzukommen, die ich nicht durch die Atmosphäre durchkommen würden
oder einfach die die Verschwemmung der Atmosphäre oder diese Bildverzerrung, die die Atmosphäre mit sich bringt eben zu vermeiden.
Anderen Fällen möchte man einfach einen ruhigen Ort kommen.
James Web zum Beispiel, dass der Nachfolger vom Hubbleter einfach an einem Punkt geschickt hinter der Erde und wird der der Erde einfach folgen
Punkt, wo die Gravitation der Erde und der Sonne sich mehr oder weniger gegenseitig aufheben, das heißt man.
Punkt zwei.
An dem Ort kann man eben einen Satelliten mit wenig Treibstoff einfach lassen, der wird sich dann nicht bewegen, der wird nicht in eine Richtung der andere eben äh die Erde verlassen.
Im Fall von möchte man natürlich die den Sattel auf eine Umlaufbahn schicken wie zum Beispiel jetzt letztens der dann wo man sich dann eben.
Auf eine Umlaufbahn bringt, die nah an der Sonne vorbeifährt, beziehungsweise für den wollten wir mal die Sonne von oben sehen. Das heißt, im Laufe von einigen Jahren werden wir anhand.
Von äh Swing-Bys, also wir andere Planeten, das Kavitationsfeld von anderen Planeten benutzen, um langsam diese Umlaufbahn ähm äh zu neigen und eben aus der,
Ebene der der Erdumlaufbahn rauskommen und mit einer Neigung dann so langsam die Bahn ähm so verschieben, dass wir dann von oben oder von einem höheren.
Auf die Sonne runter gucken können. Ähm.
Es ist dann immer noch kompliziert, wie man eben diese Satelliten äh durch unser Sonnensystem fliegt. Will man natürlich äh so komplizierte Sachen machen will wie mit äh der Mission, die nächstes Jahr startet, Ex-Omas unser ähm Rover und unsere Serviceplattform
ähm da müssen wir eben bis zum Maß fliegen, dort in der Umlaufbahn kommen und von dort aus eben den Rover und
die Serviceplattform absetzen, das ist eben auch äh kompliziert in der Navigation von Satelliten. Ähm,
Ja und das äh das muss eben alles passieren. Wenn das passiert und wir endlich dort sind oder auf der Umlaufbahn wir wollen.
Dann fangen wir endlich mit dem wissenschaftlichen Betrieb an und kommen dann dem Ziel näher eben
Wissenschaft mit dieser Mission zu betreiben, was ja von vornherein eben äh der Sinn war.
Wie lange das alles dauern kann, das äh habe ich gerade eben noch mal gesehen, weil ich sowohl äh über das vorhin schon erwähnt, der XM, was ja schon läuft, schon äh vor langer, langer Zeit, nämlich zwanzig dreizehn
eine Sendung gemacht habe. Damals schon festgestellt haben, dass es sich um eine der erfolgreichsten und langlebigsten handelt. Das äh hat sich seitdem sozusagen auch nicht geändert.
Und äh ja, nur einen Monat später äh war dann auch der Solar Orbitter im Gespräch, damals halt noch in der fernen Zukunft, zwanzig ähm
sollte der Staat sein, letzten Endes ist es dann auch erst 2020 ähm.
Gegangen und äh ja, jetzt ist das Ding noch unterwegs, wenn ich das richtig sehe, erst zwanzig dreißig erreicht. Äh der Solar Orbita äh letztlich wirklich,
täten. Später sogar.
Betrieb fängt der dieses Jahr wird er mit dem wissenschaftlichen Betrieb anfangen und wird dann hoffentlich eben bis 2030 oder noch länger eben in Betrieb sein, hoffen wir. Ähm.
Aber da stehen auch so diverse Swing-Bys irgendwie an, aber ach so, das ist dann sozusagen Teil der Mission.
Das ist Teil der Mission. Wir fangen wir fangen ähm dieses Jahr mit dem dieses Jahr an. Äh also wir haben schon die wissenschaftlichen Instrumente eingeschaltet. Wir haben auch schon Wissenschaft äh
verschiedene, also bei den äh vorbeifliegenden anderen Planeten, auch schon äh wissenschaftliche Messungen äh gemacht
und jetzt so bei jedem werden wir es schaffen, diese den Orbit dieses Satellitens so langsam mehr und mehr und mehr und mehr zu neigen. Ähm aber fangen natürlich dies Jahr schon an mit wissenschaftlichen Vermessungen und haben dann eine lange Zeitreihe, wo wir uns dann die Sonne von verschiedenen aus verschiedenen Winkeln angucken können und immer wieder,
und äh ähm die Sonne ist natürlich auch aktiv und hat so einen Zyklus von elf, beziehungsweise 22 Jahren und das heißt, wir können.
Die Sonne durch so in einen Zyklus begleiten und gucken, wie verändern sich die verschiedenen Phänomene im Laufe eines Zyklus, was äh natürlich für uns interessant ist als Stern, die Sonne ist der nächste Stern, den wir haben, wenn wir den Rest des Kosmos, der ja
Materie, hauptsächlich auf Sternen besteht, verstehen wollen, müssen wir erstmal die Sonne verstehen.
Andererseits äh ist die Sonder auch das, was am meisten Einfluss auf unser Klima hat und eben die Sonne sehr gut zu verstehen, wird uns auch sehr gut äh dabei helfen, zu verstehen, was für Klimaänderungen auf uns zukommen.
Macht man sich immer nicht so richtig klar. Also ich äh hatte eben selber so einen kleinen Gedankenfehler, so dieses Jahr, wir wollen uns nochmal die Sonne von oben anschauen. Ist ja gar nicht so einfach, wenn man irgendwie erstmal in so einem Orbit äh um die Sonne herum ist und bei der Erde startet, ein Vehikel dann überhaupt
so in diese Richtung und Geschwindigkeit zu bekommen, dass man sowas machen kann, wie von oben gucken.
Ohne jetzt gleich äh einmal vorbei und äh nimm mal wiedersehen äh zu sein. Da gehört natürlich einiges an Anpassungen dazu
Und das sind dann eben auch so Dinge, die ja auch fortwährend immer wieder überprüft werden müssen und das ist dann hier auch Teil der Arbeit.
Genau, wir haben äh und da auch ist es äh es gibt ein großes äh sogenanntes Flight Dinnermix Team in äh in Darmstadt. Äh und das sind die Leute, die diese Bahn berechnen, also die wirklich äh,
zehn Jahre im Voraus auf Millisekunden berechnen können, wann ein Sattel an welchem Planeten vorbeifliegt und in welcher Entfernung, in welcher äh Richtung er vorbei fliegen muss und wie nah,
um genau dann durch die Schwerkraft dieses Planetens in die veränderte Umlaufbahn zu kommen, in die man diese möchte.
Warum wir diese Gravitation der Planeten benutzen, ist weil unsere Trägerraketen, wenn wir eine unendlich große bauen könnten, dann könnten wir auch auf die,
Wege irgendwo hinfliegen, wo wir hinwollen. Man bräuchte dann unendlich viel Treibstoff und so weiter. Aber weil man eben äh mit dem arbeitet, mit dem was man hat und selbst unsere größten Raketen im Moment für die Europäer die Ariane 5 oder jetzt.
Die Ariane sechs, ähm eben äh nur begrenzt äh Masse hochschießen können mit begrenzt Treibstoff ähm müssen wir,
schlau der Gravitation der anderen Planeten bedienen, wenn wir wirklich weit kommen wollen. Das dauert dann oft äh länger als auf direktem äh auf auf gerader Linie.
Zum Beispiel Juice, was unsere nächste Mission zum Jupiter ist, äh startet äh zwanzig dreiundzwanzig
die wird sechs, sieben Jahre brauchen bis zum Jupiter, weil sie eben mit zu viel Schwung wie es geht die Erde verlassen wird
aber der Schwung nicht reißt bis auf direkte Bahn zum Jupiter zu kommen beziehungsweise auch nicht in genau der mit der Geschwindigkeit und der wir sie wollen, sondern der wird auch eben sechs, sieben
machen, um dann letztendlich äh dann im Jupiter anzukommen. Nach sechs, sieben Jahren.
Planeten Billard möglichst ohne Kollisionen auf jeden Fall.
Genau.
Bin ich schon so ein bisschen drum äh herum äh geeiert, aber ich würde gerne nochmal einen Fokus darauf äh legen, weil die Bodentelesgruppe spielen ja hier auch eine große Rolle.
Und ähm hast ja schon angedeutet, was ja bei dem äh ELT ganz maßstäblich mit beteiligt und das ist ja nun eigentlich auch so das nächste große Ding. Inwiefern unterscheidet sich jetzt die
Planung und die Arbeit an solchen Teleskopen von den Space
Missionen und ähm vielleicht können wir ja auch mal so ein bisschen nochmal einen Ausblick geben auf das, was das ELT leisten soll und welche Herausforderungen jetzt gerade in dieser Anbahnung dieses Projekts äh so ansteht.
Ähm ja, dazu gibt's äh viel zu erzählen. Vielleicht erstmal, dass äh es äh heutzutage,
undenkbar wäre, äh nur ein Teleskop für die Forschung zu benutzen, äh die die Wissenschaftler, egal für welches Projekt, benutzen wirklich ähm alle,
alle Teleskope, die möglichst und und äh denkbar sind und das sind äh fast immer Kombinationen von Weltraum, Teleskopen und Bodenteleskopen.
Und warum baut man überhaupt Weltraum und Bodenteleskope? Äh auf dem Boden kann man billiger bauen, es sind äh eben diese ganzen Ansprüche, das alles auf an
Anhieb funktionieren muss. Das alles auch im Weltall funktionieren muss und so weiter sind natürlich sehr äh nicht da. Das heißt, diese die Technologien sind billiger.
Ähm man braucht auch nicht präzise zu planen, weil man eben eine äh wieder.
Dran kann. Und äh da unterscheiden sich die Kosten dann oft um ein äh um ein Vielfaches. Wobei das eben auch äh eins Komma fünf Milliarden kosten wird, also da ist man auch wieder bei einem.
Einen Preis von von,
großen immer noch oder dennoch eben schon sehr teure Mission.
Warum baut man überhaupt auf dem äh bodengebunde Teleskop, wenn man hier sehr viel größere Teleskope bauen kann. Das ELT hat wird einen Spiegeldurchmesser von fast 40 Metern haben. Das heißt, man kann damit sehr, sehr viele Foton, sehr, sehr viel Licht sammeln.
Und das größte Weltraum Teleskop wird eben das Web Teleskop, das Web Teleskop sein, das hat einen sechseinhalb Meter Spiegel Durchmesser. Das heißt, wenn man viele Fotoen sammeln möchte, kann man das immer noch sehr viel effizienter vom Boden machen.
Was verliert man? Man verliert natürlich die Tatsache, dass man durch die Atmosphäre gucken muss. Das heißt, nur gewisse Wellenlängen äh erreichbar sind.
Das Web-Terskop kann eben im Infraroten und fernen Infraroten gucken, das wird das ILT nicht können.
Ähm und man muss äh sich damit abfinden, dass das Licht durch die Atmosphäre eben verzehrt wird und man äh unschärfere Bilder bekommt, als wie man über der Atmosphäre wäre.
Beziehungsweise entsprechende Strategien anwenden muss, um das äh dann wieder zu korrigieren.
Genau und das ist eben, was das ILT kann, da kann man wirklich an die äh an die Grenze der Optik gehen, an die Beugungsgrenze äh mit der mit der Schärfe der Bilder. Äh und dann hat man praktisch die ähm eine höhere Auflösung, weil die.
Auflösung eines Bildes ist umgekehrt proportional zum Durchmesser des Teleskops, das heißt, wenn man einen sehr großen Spiegel hat, hat man auch äh extrem,
Schafe Bilder beziehungsweise kann eben 'ne hohe Auflösung haben, 'ne bildliche Auflösung wenn das Teleskop kleiner ist, also wenn der Spiegeldurchmesser kleiner ist, ist die Auflösung, die bildliche Auflösung des CSUs geringer
dass es ihr Tier auf dem Boden wird, äh weil man eben diese Atmosphäre korrigiert durch adaptive Optik,
wird eine fünffache höhere bildliche Auflösung haben oder räumliche Auflösung haben als das Web-Teleskop.
Man wird also schärfere Bilder oder höhere Auflösungen Bilder machen können mit dem äh mit dem ILT. Andererseits, wie ich schon erwähnt habe, wird man sehr viel mehr Futuren.
Sammeln, das heißt.
Wenn man Spektroskopie betreibt, also das Licht bricht in in all seine Bestandteile in den ganzen Wellenlängen. Ähm es gibt bei Auflösung, also wie fein,
bricht man dieses Licht
wenig Futuren hat, dann kann man's eben nur äh grob brechen, äh um dann noch genug bei jeder Wellenlänge zu haben, um was zu vermessen. Wir werden extrem viele Futuren sammelt, kann man das eben sehr, sehr hoch auf,
mit einer hohen Spektralen Auflösung. Und das ILT wird also praktisch.
Da wo es mehr können wird, als das Web-Teleskop ist eben in der räumlichen Auflösung und in der Spektralenauflösung. Und da wo das Web-Disko,
dem ihr zu überlegen sein wird, ist eben in der Empfindlichkeit und insbesondere auch in dem es eben vorstoßen kann in den Infrarotbereich,
also für Messungen im fernen Universum, wo eben äh das Licht.
Ähm zehn Milliarden Jahre äh gewandert durchs Universum und sich rot verschoben hat, also im Infraroten gelandet ist,
Da wird es äh Web-Teleskop dem überlegen sein, den bodengebundenen Teleskopen.
Und für kalte Objekte, die hauptsächlich im Infraroten äh eben äh Licht ausstrahlen, zum Beispiel Exo-Planeten, da wird auch das Web empfindlicher sein als das bodengebundene Teleskop.
Es ist aber genauso geplant, dass eben diese zwei Teleskope des Web äh Weltraum Teleskop und das äh European Extremiscoup auf dem Boden eben sich komplementieren und die meisten Forschungsprojekte werden wirklich beide benutzen.
Beziehungsweise ist ja der Trend zur Multiteleskopie äh voll äh.
Entflammt, nicht zuletzt mit diesem Event Horizon, Teleskop Projekt, was ja ohnehin äh alle Beobachtungsmöglichkeiten des Planeten zusammen
geschlossen hat, um um dieses schwarze Loch äh endlich mal ähm visualisieren zu können, sage ich mal, fotografieren ist vielleicht nicht die richtige Begriff.
Genau, da waren Leute eben sehr kreativ und haben eben sehr, sehr viele Teleskope zusammengeschlossen. Was im im äh im Radiowellenling Bereich geht, weil da die Wellen sehr lang sind und man eben sehr genau vermessen kann, wann sie ankommen.
Diese Art von Technologie kann man eben noch nicht im Infraroten oder optischen verwenden aber die Hoffnung ist, dass wenn's irgendwann mal auch kann, wenn man,
Uhren baut, die die präzise genug sind, ja?
Mhm. Romzahl, 4undsiebzig hat sich mit den schwarzen Löchern äh beschäftigt, also konkret mit dem Event Reisen, Teleskop-Projekt als das erste Bild äh rauskam, habe ich mit Michael äh Kramer gesprochen und äh ja auch
über die Bodenteleskope hatte ich auch schon mitm alten Kollegen äh von dir Jochen Liske, 8undsechzig, zwanzigzehn7 haben wir das äh schon aufgenommen. Da ging's auch um die ganze Geschichte der bodengestützten Astrodomien. Da haben wir auch schon so einen ersten äh,
blick gewagt auf das äh ELT sicherlich damals auch noch mit anderen Erwartungshaltungen, wann es denn nun äh vielleicht in Betrieb gehen kann, wie sieht's denn da gerade aus, wann
Wann wird denn das dann sein?
Also im Moment ist es es war geplant für 2024 dann ist die Pandemie dazwischen gekommen
äh Chile ähm hart getroffen hat
das heißt die Bauarbeiten auf dem Bau Berg selber wurden ausgesetzt und bis jetzt auch wieder die die Industrie sich sammelt und wieder anfängt
hat sich das ganze Projekt jetzt um äh etwa zwei Jahre verschoben. Also man rechnet damit, dass das äh erste Licht vom ILT 226 empfangen worden ist.
Und um den Kontext zu setzen, also ich habe auf dem, also äh Jochen, dem du gerade erwähnt hast und ich habe schon äh Anfang der Zweitausender Jahre da drauf gearbeitet, zweitausendfünf, zweitausendacht äh also zwischenzeitlich so fünf und zweitausendacht haben wir da schon mitgemacht. Zweitausendacht haben wir das übernommen
die wissenschaftliche Leitung und zweitausendzwölf
hatten wir eigentlich das Teleskop definiert, hatten das Konzept und dachten jetzt muss es nur noch gebaut werden. Und und jetzt sehen wir das eben vierzehn Jahre.
Dauern wird, bis das eben fertiggestellt wird. Das war noch Technologien, da hatten wir wirklich die, die Ingenieure bis ans äußere Ende
gepusht äh und das ein fantastisches Teleskop äh werden, aber daran sieht man eben auch, dass diese Projekte äh wirklich lange dauern, ne.
Aber jetzt im Vergleich zu den Space Missionen, wo ja klar ist, dass man diesen Freeze machen muss, weil irgendwann muss man's ja mal bauen, gilt sicherlich in gewisser Hinsicht auch fürs Bundtestkop, aber wie sehr ändert sich die Technologie äh auf dem Weg dahin,
bis es denn wirklich mal gebaut ist.
Diese die Technologie für das ILT, für den, für das Teleskop selber von den Instrumenten absieht. Ähm da waren wir wirklich so an der Grenze der Technologie, dass ähm.
In den
zehn Jahren, zwischen äh dem äh dem Einfrieren und äh der Fertigstellung sich nicht sehr viel tun wird. Ähm das sind äh Messungsverfahren, Schleifungsverfahren, die entwickeln sich relativ langsam, beziehungsweise
die sponsern praktisch die die Wissenschaften, äh die Sponsoren, die Entwicklungsarbeit in der Industrie, um überhaupt diese Technologien zu entwickeln.
Die Industrie hätten sie nicht es gibt manche Technologien die die Industrie nicht selber entwickelt hätte wenn wir sie nicht sponsern würden also das ist nicht so das wenn wir warten würden plötzlich diese Technologien erscheinen würden.
Und äh ich glaube da für das ILT speziell für das Teleskop ähm hat sich in zehn Jahren.
Nicht eine Technologie radikal gewandelt. Bei der Instrumentierung ähm,
Da hat man äh bei der bodengebundenen Gastronomie auch gewisse Grenzen erreicht, weil ähm.
In den 80er, 90er Jahren hat man an den Detektoren sehr viel gearbeitet. Also man hatte da, man ist für ihn von alten Fotoplatten zur elektronischen Detektoren, zu CCDs übergegangen. Ähm heutzutage hat man dieses Device, die eben auch in jedem Mobiltelefon drin sind
die sind.
Da hat ein Gastronom eine Technologie entwickelt, die wirklich jedes Lichtwand einfangen, weil wenn eine Lichtquand eben zehn Milliarden Jahre durchs Weltall gereist ist, dann müsste man nicht, dass man es auf den Detektor trifft und da gar nicht
aufgenommen wird, ähm weil er dieses Texto nicht empfindlich genug ist. Das heißt, diese Sektoren, die wir mitentwickelt haben mit der Industrie, die hatten Quantenausbeuten von 90 Prozent Plus.
Eine Mobiltelefon, da da ist es meistens zu hell tagsüber, dass wenn man dann einfach nur ein Foto nehmen will, es reicht, wenn man 30, 40 Prozent Quantenausbeute hat oder oder noch geringer. Ähm das heißt, da hat sich die Psychologie etwas anders entwickelt, weil die Industrie.
Arbeitet nicht nur für die Gastronomen, sondern hauptsächlich da, wo eben ähm Markt ist und und Geschäft. Ähm
und äh da hat da haben wir praktisch eine gewisse Grenze erreicht an an den Diktoren
was Optiken angeht, da ist auch Telekommunikation, hat uns da enorm in die Hände gespielt, weil der Kommunikationsmarkt mit Optiken, äh mit ähm
Glasfasern und so weiter eben sehr viel an den Entwicklung von Optiken mitgearbeitet und geholfen hat,
da wird sich aber auch nicht sehr viel tun, das heißt bei der Instrumentierung auf im optischen oder nach wie vor.
Haben wir auch eine gewisse Grenze erreicht, da wird man auch nicht mehr so einen Quantensprung schaffen in in den nächsten Jahren. Das heißt, indem wir die Technologien uns festgelegt haben vor zehn Jahren, haben wir nicht so viel verloren
ähm in dem Sinne, dass wenn wir jetzt äh
fünf bis zehn Jahre gewartet hätten, bevor wir die Instrumentierung definiert hätten, äh wir plötzlich eine sehr viel bessere Instrumentierung hätten heutzutage.
Man viele Stationen hat für Instrumentierungen und es auch geplant ist, diese Instrumentierung regelmäßig zu ersetzen.
Das kann man bei einer Weltraummission natürlich nicht. Man hat ein Teleskop oder einen Satelliten. Man packt
die Instrumentierung drauf und damit muss man dann praktisch die nächsten zehn, zwanzig, dreißig Jahre manchmal erleben. Und dann ist die Technologie dort natürlich veraltet und man hätte natürlich was, äh wenn man's ersetzen könnte, was man früher beim,
Tedesco beim Pavel.
Noch machen konnte. Hm.
Da konnte man eben ab und zu mal wieder hoch fliegen und die Astronauten haben dann praktisch ein Instrument ersetzt durch ein anderes.
Seitdem das Programm eingestellt worden ist, kann man das nicht mehr beim Hubbel und,
hat damit gerechnet, dass es jemals wieder möglich sein wird das heißt James Web zum Beispiel wird ja zum da haben wir,
drüber geredet, geschickt äh eine Millionen Kilometer von der Erde entfernt. Da fliegt man keine Astronauten mehr hin. Ähm und ähm ja bei.
Bodengebundene Teleskopen, da ist es mit eingeplant, dass die Instrumentierung eben äh irgendwann mal ähm gewechselt wird und dann könnte man neue Technologien.
Einbauen, wobei man, wenn man
Ein einzelnes Teleskop hat wie das ILT, anstatt zum Beispiel vier, wie bei einem äh VIT, also acht Meterklasse Teleskope
konnte drei Instrumente aufnehmen, das heißt man hatte zwölf verschiedene Instrumente gleichzeitig, man konnte sich eben da eine Palette an Instrumentierung.
Vom UV bis zum Infraroten über optisch über äh äh bildgebende Instrumente über Spektrum, Feinauflösen, grob auflösen und so weiter. Beim ILT hat man nur ein Tedisko.
Und äh da wird man versuchen.
So viele Instrumente wie möglich, gleichzeitig dran zu betreiben, aber die müssen sich das Teleskop teilen, das heißt, sie können auch nicht gleichzeitig alle beobachten. Äh und da muss man sich dann eben ein bisschen äh genauer überlegen.
Instrument möchte man am Teleskop montieren, wie lange möchte man's dran haben? Wann hat's sein Zweck erfüllt.
Und so weiter. Also es ist ein bisschen ein anderer Planungsprozess beim beim ILTS, beim, beim VIT.
Jetzt wird ja das ELT von der E so betrieben oder auch mit geplant.
Also es ist ja ursprünglich dort quasi entwickelt worden. Ähm wie sieht diese Kooperation jetzt konkret aus? Also verstehe ich das richtig, dass
das I sagt jetzt an dieser Stelle quasi so Operationsdienstleister ist und dem E so mehr oder weniger die Wissenschaft zuführt oder die Daten
die von der ESO kommen, den Wissenschaftlern zuführt, ist das dann äh die primäre Rolle äh ab dem Tag, wo das Ding im Betrieb ist, ähm wie muss man sich diesen Verbund vorstellen von
unterschiedlich angelegten Organisationen.
Es sind ähm letztendlich sind es zwei äh Schwesterorganisationen, die eh so und die E sah. Ähm und wenn man sich die Strukturen anguckt
das sind eben ähm auf Englisch äh Organisations, also äh äh mehr staatliche eben Organisationen. Die haben fast exakt dieselben Statuten, sind auf einem englischen Prinzip aufgebaut,
und sind und sehen sich glaub ich als gleichwertig nur die einen sind zuständig die anderen für Weltraum-Astronomie und wir spielen uns die wissenschaftlich
die Wissenschaft,
gegenseitig zu sozusagen. Also es ist nicht so, als würden äh als würden wir bei der Esa jetzt mit so einer Weltraummission die Grundlagen schaffen, die dann das äh ILT, die bodengebundene Gastronomie braucht,
sondern ingekehrt, wo die
Bodengebundene Gastronomie eben die Weltraumgastronomie bedient. Ähm und jetzt an dem Beispiel äh YLT und Web, also ähm ist es so, dass äh wir sicherlich Entdeckungen mit dem ILT machen werden, die mit dem äh Web dann weiter äh verfolgt werden
müssen oder können. Ähm aber das äh das Gegenteil gilt dann auch, wo dann in Deckung mit dem Webdriscoup gemacht werden.
Dann unbedingt das ILT brauchen, um äh um dann wirklich zum zum Kern äh.
Ja gut, aber wenn ich jetzt so so Teil einer Wissenschaftsgruppe äh wäre, dir ist der Meinung, dass hier 40 Meter äh da müssen wir unbedingt mal irgendwas mit beobachten. So, wo laufe ich denn als erstes hin? So Iso oder zu Isaak?
Also wenn wenn man das Programm, also aber oft denken die Gruppen, also wir sind ja beide Dienstleister, sowohl die ESO als auch die sind beides Dienstleister, wie stellen die Teleskope zur Verfügung, diesen Vorschussgruppen.
Und äh äh.
In den meisten Fällen werden diese Forschungsgruppen, die meinetwegen eben eine Kollaboration in in drei drei Mitgliedsländern, drei europäischen Ländern irgendwie von verschiedenen Unis da zusammenkommen, die werden
Anträge an beiden Stellen. Also sie werden sagen, hier wir haben ein super Projekt, dazu brauchen wir aber das ILT und das Web zum Beispiel
und die werden gleichzeitig bei beiden Anträge stellen und sagen und wir möchten eine äh wir brauchen Daten von beiden Teleskopen
um äh um unser Projekt zu realisieren. Äh und die werden dann von beiden begutachtet. In manchen Fällen gibt's sogar eben äh schließen wir uns kurz und äh wenn's wirklich große.
Daten sind, zum Beispiel, ich hatte vorhin Plato erwähnt, diese Durchmusterung von Exemplaten, da haben wir schon eben von vorne rein, also bevor dieser Sattel überhaupt fliegt, sind wir in Kontakt getreten mit der Esel und gesagt, um damit dieses Programm, diese Durchmüssung erfolgreich ist,
müssen wir eben so und so viel Teleskopzeit äh Bodengebunden reservieren, um eben äh diese ganze Nachbeobachtung zu machen. Und da entstehen dann eben praktisch schon im vor äh im Voraus Deals.
Okay, aber das ILT ist generell.
Sozusagen eher so macht die Zuteilung für äh das ELT, Esa macht Zuteilung für die Space äh Mission, das ist schon relativ klar getrennt, aber es gibt doch auch bodengeschützte Teleskope, die jetzt direkt an der ISAG noch mit dranhängen.
Es gibt auch Bunt, also es gibt Boden äh also.
Anderem hier direkt auf dem Campus, wenn ich das richtig sehe, ne? Die.
Ähm das sind Antennen, das sind da die benutzen wir eigentlich nur wirklich zur ähm also die.
Zur Kommunikation.
Kommunikation, also wir haben hier äh zwei 15 Meter Antennen auf dem Campus. Wir haben dann eine eine dreißig Meter Antenne, die etwas weiter hier ähm äh von Madrid eine Stunde entfernt ist. Äh die benutzen wir jetzt zur Kommunikation. Das einzige Teleskop, das wir auf der anderen Seite hier auf dem Campus haben
benutzen wir eigentlich mehr für für Lehrzwecke. Wir haben hier sehr viele Schulen und und machen auch eben Arbeit.
Ist noch ein Bund, Teleskop jetzt unmittelbar unter der Egide der Isark.
Der Esack nicht. Wir haben andere, wo wir kleinere Teleskope benutzen, also wir haben auch 'nen es gibt tatsächlich was mit dem pompösen Titel Planetary Defense Abteilung bei der EsA
Objekte angucken, die in Erdnähe kämen oder kommen würden oder kommen äh und um die zu durchmustern
da gibt's da gibt's Projekte auch zusammen mit der ESO
um eben Teleskop aufzustellen, auch auf äh auf Standorten der EZO und dort eben äh diese äh Vorbereitung oder oder Warnsystem im ähm.
Programme, ne.
Festivals. Genau, die erstes A Programme, da drunter fällt es eben.
Genau. Hatte ich auch schon mal. Raumzeit 4unddreißig äh mit Detlef äh Koschni.
Ja, der verarbeitet auch bei uns, also ist in in unserem Department und macht weiter eben diese Sachen, ja.
Eine große Familie ah hier alles auf jeden Fall.
Genau, hier, nee, wir sind äh wir
Ja, wir arbeiten alle zusammen. Wir hängen irgendwie alle äh äh helfen uns gegenseitig und und versuchen auch die die gegenseitig die Infrastruktur zu nutzen. Aber diese diese äh also sozusagen in Europa sind das wirklich zwei getrennte Organisationen, ESO und EsA
aber wir haben eben ständig Kontakt und und viele meiner Kollegen haben entweder vorher bei der EsA gearbeitet und arbeiten jetzt bei der ESO oder haben vorher bei der ESO gearbeitet und arbeiten jetzt bei der wie ich zum Beispiel und und dadurch sind eben die Netzwerke sehr, sehr, sehr eng.
Mhm. Gibt's auch so Missionen, die scheitern.
Ähm gibt es aber selten, weil eben dieser Planungsprozess so rigoros und so lang ist, dass ähm äh.
Dass es oft äh also, dass es kaum zu Ausfällen kommt. Ähm wir sitzen hier aber gerade in einem Raum, wo so ein paar Exponate rumstehen ähm und äh eins da auf der Fensterbank
ein Teil der gecrashten Cluster Mission. Ähm das sind äh das ist eine Konstellation von vier Satelliten. Die wurden in Paaren äh hochgeschickt
und 1 damals äheins dieser dieser Staats ist eben misslungen. Äh die Satelliten sind eben äh zurück auf die Erde gecrasht und äh ein Bruchteil davon sehen wir hier auf der Fensterbank, um uns dran zu erinnern, dass eben nicht alles immer klappt
Ähm in dem Fall wurden die zwei Salzlitten aber wieder nachgebaut und diese Viererkonstellation fliegt tatsächlich seit,
jetzt auch überdenken aber wahrscheinlich 15 Jahren oder so
Sie haben langsam ausgedient der Treibstoff geht uns aus und der erste von diesen vieren wird Ende 2024 wieder verglühen in der Erdatmosphäre
und dann in zwei Jahren drauf, dann die weiteren drei. Ähm das ist eine Mission, die hier dies äh hauptsächlich ähm.
Die das Strahlungsfeld der der Sonne in Erdnähe äh vermessen hat ähm und eben um äh um zu verstehen, wie die wie unsere Erde das Magnetfelder Erde mit der äh mit dem Sonnenwind interagiert.
Aber das ist da war der erste Start der ist misslungen und wir hatten auch ein paar andere Missionen, Kooperationen mit teilweise auch anderen Weltraumagenturen.
Ähm
wo äh wo es kleine Fehler gab, ähm Hubbel hatte man ein ganz berühmtes Beispiel. Da wurde ja die Optik fast geschliffen und äh in den ersten Jahren hat man sich äh hat man das Leben bemerkt und musste dann an der eine Brille schleifen für die dann eingesetzt worden ist.
Und die immer noch.
Ist noch was zu retten.
Ja genau. Also meistens versuchen wir dieses Mission zu retten. Welche die richtig schief,
gelaufen sind, das ist, glaube ich, das sind wirklich die Ausnahmen. Also ähm wie gesagt, der Prozess ist so rigoros, dass äh äh wir doch versuchen, normalerweise sehr äh vorsichtig mit den Steuergeldern umzugehen, ja.
Ich denke, unterm Strich kann man auch mal sagen, dass eigentlich so die Zuverlässigkeit aller Missionen doch sehr hoch ist, also das meiste startet irgendwann, vielleicht verspätet, vielleicht ein bisschen teurer, aber dann fliegen sie und in allermeisten Fällen ähm
sind ja dann auch die Ergebnisse ähm so wie ich das so wahrnehme über die Zeit.
Eigentlich immer läuft immer alles länger als mal gedacht war und es kommt mir aber raus, als man sich erhofft hat. Das muss ja nicht unbedingt immer so.
Als ich gewählt habe, erwähnt habe, dass die unsere Ingenieure sehr konservativ sind. Also.
Das hilft.
Genau, also das das hilft enorm. Das heißt, dass wenn man sagt, okay, das muss so mit neunundneunzig Kommaneun neun Prozent Sicherheit eben äh mindestens fünf Jahre lang funktionieren, dann ist eben die Wahrscheinlichkeit auch hoch, dass es eben auch
zehn Jahre alt oder vielleicht sogar 20 Jahre hält oder wie in Pfaffen Herbert sogar 30 Jahre hält, obwohl es eben ursprünglich nur für fünf geplant war. Aber da baut man eben.
Weil es auf Anhieb sofort und absolut sicher klappen muss, äh wird so viel Spielraum eingebaut, dass man dann, wenn man's will und und kann äh die Mission tatsächlich für sehr viel längere Zeit betreiben kann, wo wir uns dann eben immer sehr freuen als Wissenschaftler.
Ja und oft ist es ja dann auch die Kreativität der äh missionsbegleitenden
Wissenschaftler und Ingenieure, die dann Winz dann mal gestartet ist und trotzdem fällt irgendetwas aus. Es gibt da mal so einen Vorfall zum Beispiel, hat man hier auch schon mal auf dem Anflug
wo du ja dann auch noch sozusagen unterwegs äh die Strategie äh geändert, um ähm Dinge zu retten.
Es gibt extrem viele Beispiele, also ähm die Mission, die wir gerade erwähnt haben, Cluster, diese Konstellation von vier Satelliten, der hat natürlich eine Batterie eingebaut, denn die mit
ganz klassisch mit so Sonnensegeln eben oder Sonnenpanelen eben aufgeladen werden und so weiter. Die Batterien sind irgendwo mal ausgefallen und die Mission konnte trotzdem weiter,
werden, weil man da eben dann äh kein Strom mehr gespeichert hat, sondern eben einfach,
genutzt hat, von den äh Sonnenpanelen. Äh andere Beispiele sind äh sind. Man baut äh um dich für die Stabilisierung und Ausrichtung des äh eines Satelliten,
baut man Jyros ein, also äh Spinnräder äh und äh man hat's geplant, mit viel zu betreiben, dann fiel eins aus, dann das nächste und das dritte und dann haben sie letztendlich festgestellt
zerhabelt könnte man auch mit einem Spinnrad, äh also man hatte sechs eingebaut wegen Redulanzen. Man hat's immer geplant mit mindestens drei zu betreiben und vier eventuell. Und mittlerweile ist es mit zwei Betrieben und man weiß auch schon, wie man's mit allen betreiben könnte. Also,
dieser Einbau der Resonanzen heißt, dass dass Sachen ausfallen können und wenn die das Leben trotzdem betreiben kann. Auch wieder dieses konservative Denken
Also ich sage immer, konservativ, das ist vielleicht ein negativ behaftetes Wort, aber einfach dieses äh diese Planungssicherheit, die die Ingenieur einbauen, also diese.
Tatsache, dass sie sich bewusst sind, dass auch wenn mal was schief läuft, eben daran nicht die komplette Mission scheitern darf. Ähm äh und dann eben diese Kreativität. Also wir haben Kollegen bei der E-Sock in Darmstadt, die ich immer wieder bewundere, weil die mit Ideen kommen, wenn mal was nicht funktioniert, wo auch was, was.
Nicht so geplant war
dann irgendeiner mit 'ner mit 'ner tollen Idee kommt wie man das dann trotzdem noch auspennen könnte oder ein anderes System an Bord das überhaupt nicht davor vorgesehen worden ist, benutzen kann um dann doch noch diese Funktion zu erfüllen und so
also die sind immer sehr kreativ und äh das macht ihnen auch Spaß und äh und uns hilft es, weil wir die Mission länger betreiben, betrieben werden können.
Ja, jetzt im Dezember startet hoffentlich dann das äh James Web, das ist ja die Kooperation mit der NASA. Was ist so die die nächste reine ISA-Mission oder die federführend von der EsA geleitet wird, die dann hier äh äh starten wird.
Diese also diese Durchmusterung ähm um die die des äh entfernte Universum, also äh dunkle Materie, dunkle Energie eben zu durchmustern oder zu äh zur Katografieren im Universum
das startet Ende 22, Anfang 23 es ist so der Zeitraum
da da hat man kein besonderes Zeitfenster, weil das eben 'ne Erdumlaufbahn ist
etwa um den selben zum selben Zeitpunkt starten wir auch im Juice, das ist unsere Jupiter, den ich erwähnt hatte
weil man zum Jupiter fliegen muss und diese ganzen komplizierten äh zu anderen Planeten, haben diese Planetarischen Missionen äh oft einfach also ziemlich enge Zeitfenster, zu dem sie starten können und äh Ju.
Ein, zwei Wochen oder so.
Genau und hat äh ein, zwei Wochen hat Juice jetzt äh im September zweiundzwanzig äh und dann nochmal ein Fenster im August dreiundzwanzig. Also wenn wir's äh können und schaffen, dann werden wir die September zweiundzwanzig starten
wie wir das den Zeitraum verpassen müssen wir fast ein Jahr warten bis wir den nächsten, das nächste Zeitfenster haben um in die richtige Richtung zu fliegen und dann zum beim Jupiter anzukommen.
Ähm das, also Jugendliche und Juice sind die zwei großen Missionen, die wir äh,
die wird demnächst starten. Wir haben jetzt praktisch ein Start pro Jahr mit mit Web, mit Juice, mit. Das ist äh ungewöhnlich, aber wir freuen uns natürlich riesig, dass es passiert. Äh.
Ungewöhnlich, dass es in diesem Abstand.
Ungewöhnlich, dass wir wirklich jedes Jahr eine größere Mission starten. Das ist äh äh das.
Ja, das äh in der Regel haben wir das Geld nicht, um das zu schaffen. Da war jetzt Web hat sich verzögert, ähm nur kaum und dadurch haben wir jetzt so ein bisschen geballten.
Und weil wir auch eben vor kurzem, du hast es erwähnt, äh Solar Orbitter zwanzigzwanzig eben auch schon hoch,
haben und äh kurz vorher so eine kleinere Mission aber auch haben wir wieder viel äh viel zu betreiben.
In der Regel betreiben wir etwa einen Dutzend äh Mission äh auf einmal
und haben ein anderes Dutzend in der Planung, sodass es so praktisch unser Zyklus und das sind kleinere und größere und wenn man bedenkt, dass sie in 10 bis 20 Jahre brauchen, haben wir.
Also dir in der Regel vielleicht eher einen einen Launch, alle zwei Jahre äh und eben nur, wenn's mal sich ein bisschen komprimiert, dann dann jedes Jahr.
Ja, da wünsche ich auf jeden Fall äh viel Erfolg für die nächsten äh Missionen. Äh ich hab's natürlich auch schon oft angesprochen und ich spüre es auch immer wieder, jedes bei jedem Gespräch äh
an dem Tag, wo so etwas startet, muss die Nervosität hier wirklich zum zum Schneiden sein, also das ähm kann man.
Es ist äh
ja ja das ist wirken sehr drauf. Die soll auch dabei irgendwie nachts um vier oder so und dann haben sich tatsächlich alle Mitarbeiter also wer wollte konnte eben herkommen. Wir haben Frühstück organisiert äh also nachts dann Frühstück äh und und der Raum war
proposvoll, also da kommt dann äh das ist wirklich das sind die Events. Äh und wenn man's, wenn's geht natürlich, wir schicken kleine Teams dann immer auch zu den äh zu den Orten, wo die
die Lounge passieren. In der Regel für die in Koru, in ähm in Französisch.
Wurde zum Beispiel von geschickt und,
Das ist eben auch was, was schön ist bei der Eser. Wir haben Kollaboration mit allen anderen Weltraumagenturen. Was die anderen Weltraumagenturen unter sich eben kaum können, weil
Die Amerikaner mit den Chinesen nicht können und die Russen wiederum nicht mit den Japanern oder sonst was. Und wir haben eben äh wirklich gute Kolorationen und und die Hälfte unserer Mission mindestens sind äh Kollaborationen zwischen diesen verschiedenen Agenturen. Das ist immer auch sehr spannend.
Europa redet mit allen. Das ist gut, ja, ich auch. Vielen, vielen Dank für die Ausführung hier zu den zu den ganzen Operationen äh des E-Sak und äh wie das hier so ab.
Einblicke. Ich.
Einige der angesprochenen Missionen hier demnächst dann auch noch mit abdecken. Ja, aber bis dahin äh freue ich mich, wenn ihr auch weiterhin hier wieder äh zuhört und einschaltet und für heute sage ich dann äh tschüss und.